it's in the news every day just this
month three 17-year olds were killed a
boy of 16 found dying on the estate this
is a scenario being played out in
communities across the country but where
do you go when you know someone wants to
stab you the answer is right here this
is the only way Akron Steve this is a
safe house one of 23 properties across
London being used to protect gang
members victims and perpetrators of
violent crime the knife wounds across
fourteen-year-old DeMars body tell a
horrifying tale just last month he was
chased down a busy road and stabbed
seven times when I got stabbed I did an
otter saw that the blood onto my shoes
and everything then I thought that
really dizzy I never really thought it
to be honest until sort of blood and
then that's when I caught the aching
pain when I started meeting the body
parts I go starting in the last five
years the number of teenagers like damar
being treated for knife wounds has risen
by 55 percent he's now turned his life
around and is warning other young people
not to carry knives I was carrying all
the types of weapons there was even a
time where my mom caught me with Rambo
that was about eight to seven inches
long there's literally two most deaths
and too much things happening right now
these weapons were handed over by gang
members to the pastor's who run the safe
houses all of which are self-funded I've
had to remove people from East London
and put them in South overnight
otherwise they would die before the days
over or they would kill someone so if
I'm not on call or the leaders are not
on call almost 24/7 we know that that
person would die or be killed
the next day those under 18 like Akers
he was dealing drugs on the streets
until recently require consent from the
local authority in order to be allowed
to live in one of these houses before
the drug thing started I'll just go out
couple boys and little people no Clara
lighting knives
cautious guns maybe even a acid stuff
like that why do you think it's become
the norm for so many young people to
carry weapons and also be willing to use
them to kill people when you have like
the the drive to get money you do
anything for them and I pray for every
young person to come out of it to come
out of the drug to come out of the drugs
gang to come out there killing a young
boy will stop quite close to here so
could a network of safe houses be one of
the solutions to tackling knife crime
you can't police your way out of nice
crime and use of violence you do have to
have an effective policing operation but
the public understands you have to have
a holistic solution and I think these
safe houses may well be part of it
DeMarre is one of a hundred young people
now rehoused and living in safe houses
something many now see as an answer to a
growing crisis no Philips Sky News